People are funny.
We're constantly trying
to understand and interpret
the world around us.
I live in a house with two black cats,
and let me tell you,
every time I see a black, bunched up
sweater out of the corner of my eye,
I think it's a cat.
It's not just the things we see.
Sometimes we attribute more intelligence
than might actually be there.
Maybe you've seen the dogs on TikTok.
They have these little buttons
that say things like "walk" or "treat."
They can push them to communicate
some things with their owners,
and their owners think they use them
to communicate some
pretty impressive things.
But do the dogs know what they're saying?
Or perhaps you've heard the story
of Clever Hans the horse,
and he could do math.
And not just like, simple math problems,
really complicated ones,
like, if the eighth day of the month
falls on a Tuesday,
what's the date of the following Friday?
It's like, pretty impressive for a horse.
Unfortunately, Hans wasn't doing math,
but what he was doing
was equally impressive.
Hans had learned to watch
the people in the room
to tell when he should tap his hoof.
So he communicated his answers
by tapping his hoof.
It turns out that if you know the answer
to "if the eighth day of the month
falls on a Tuesday,
what's the date of the following Friday,"
you will subconsciously
change your posture
once the horse has given
the correct 18 taps.
So Hans couldn't do math,
but he had learned to watch the people
in the room who could do math,
which, I mean, still pretty
impressive for a horse.
But this is an old picture,
and we would not fall
for Clever Hans today.
Or would we?
Well, I work in AI,
and let me tell you, things are wild.
There have been multiple examples
of people being completely convinced
that AI understands them.
In 2022,
a Google engineer thought
that Google’s AI was sentient.
And you may have had
a really human-like conversation
with something like ChatGPT.
But models we're training today
are so much better
than the models we had
even five years ago.
It really is remarkable.
So at this super crazy moment in time,
let’s ask the super crazy question:
Does AI understand us,
or are we having our own
Clever Hans moment?
Some philosophers think that computers
will never understand language.
To illustrate this, they developed
something they call
the Chinese room argument.
In the Chinese room, there is a person,
hypothetical person,
who does not understand Chinese,
but he has along with him
a set of instructions
that tell him how to respond in Chinese
to any Chinese sentence.
Here's how the Chinese room works.
A piece of paper comes in
through a slot in the door,
has something written in Chinese on it.
The person uses their instructions
to figure out how to respond.
They write the response down
on a piece of paper
and then send it back out
through the door.
To somebody who speaks Chinese,
standing outside this room,
it might seem like the person
inside the room speaks Chinese.
But we know they do not,
because no knowledge of Chinese
is required to follow the instructions.
Performance on this task does not show
that you know Chinese.
So what does that tell us about AI?
Well, when you and I stand
outside of the room,
when we speak to one
of these AIs like ChatGPT,
we are the person standing
outside the room.
We're feeding in English sentences,
we're getting English sentences back.
It really looks like
the models understand us.
It really looks like they know English.
But under the hood,
these models are just following
a set of instructions, albeit complex.
How do we know if AI understands us?
To answer that question,
let's go back to the Chinese room again.
Let's say we have two Chinese rooms.
In one Chinese room is somebody
who actually speaks Chinese,
and in the other room is our impostor.
When the person who actually
speaks Chinese gets a piece of paper
that says something in Chinese in it,
they can read it, no problem.
But when our imposter gets it again,
he has to use his set of instructions
to figure out how to respond.
From the outside, it might be impossible
to distinguish these two rooms,
but we know inside something
really different is happening.
To illustrate that,
let's say inside the minds
of our two people,
inside of our two rooms,
is a little scratch pad.
And everything they have to remember
in order to do this task
has to be written
on that little scratch pad.
If we could see what was written
on that scratch pad,
we would be able to tell how different
their approach to the task is.
So though the input and the output
of these two rooms
might be exactly the same,
the process of getting from input
to output -- completely different.
So again, what does that tell us about AI?
Again, if AI, even if it generates
completely plausible dialogue,
answers questions
just like we would expect,
it may still be an imposter of sorts.
If we want to know if AI understands
language like we do,
we need to know what it's doing.
We need to get inside
to see what it's doing.
Is it an imposter or not?
We need to see its scratch pad,
and we need to be able to compare it
to the scratch pad of somebody
who actually understands language.
But like scratch pads in brains,
that's not something
we can actually see, right?
Well, it turns out that we can
kind of see scratch pads in brains.
Using something like fMRI or EEG,
we can take what are like little snapshots
of the brain while it’s reading.
So have people read words or stories
and then take pictures of their brain.
And those brain images are like fuzzy,
out-of-focus pictures
of the scratch pad of the brain.
They tell us a little bit
about how the brain is processing
and representing information
while you read.
So here are three brain images taken
while a person read the word "apartment,"
"house" and "celery."
You can see just with your naked eye
that the brain image
for "apartment" and "house"
are more similar to each other
than they are to the brain
image for "celery."
And you know, of course that apartments
and houses are more similar
than they are to celery, just the words.
So said another way,
the brain uses its scratchpad when reading
the words "apartment" and "house"
in a way that's more similar
than when you read the word "celery."
The scratch pad tells us a little bit
about how the brain
represents the language.
It's not a perfect picture
of what the brain's doing,
but it's good enough.
OK, so we have scratch pads for the brain.
Now we need a scratch pad for AI.
So inside a lot of AIs
is a neural network.
And inside of a neural network
is a bunch of these little neurons.
So here the neurons
are like these little gray circles.
And we would like to know
what is the scratch pad
of a neural network?
Well, when we feed in a word
into a neural network,
each of the little neurons
computes a number.
Those little numbers
I'm representing here with colors.
So every neuron computes
this little number,
and those numbers tell us something
about how the neural network
is processing language.
Taken together,
all of those little circles
paint us a picture
of how the neural network
is representing language,
and they give us the scratch pad
of the neural network.
OK, great.
Now we have two scratch pads,
one from the brain and one from AI.
And we want to know: Is AI doing something
like what the brain is doing?
How can we test that?
Here's what researchers have come up with.
We're going to train a new model.
That new model is going to look
at neural network scratch pad
for a particular word
and try to predict the brain scratch pad
for the same word.
We can do it, by the way, around two.
So let's train a new model.
It’s going to look at the neural network
scratch pad for a particular word
and try to predict the brain scratchpad.
If the brain and AI
are doing nothing alike,
have nothing in common,
we won't be able to do
this prediction task.
It won't be possible to predict
one from the other.
So we've reached a fork in the road
and you can probably tell
I'm about to tell you one of two things.
I’m going to tell you AI is amazing,
or I'm going to tell you
AI is an imposter.
Researchers like me love to remind you
that AI is nothing like the brain.
And that is true.
But could it also be the AI and the brain
share something in common?
So we’ve done this scratch pad
prediction task,
and it turns out, 75 percent of the time
the predicted neural network scratchpad
for a particular word
is more similar to the true neural network
scratchpad for that word
than it is to the neural
network scratch pad
for some other randomly chosen word --
75 percent is much better than chance.
What about for more complicated things,
not just words,
but sentences, even stories?
Again, this scratch pad
prediction task works.
We’re able to predict the neural network
scratch pad from the brain and vice versa.
Amazing.
So does that mean
that neural networks and AI
understand language just like we do?
Well, truthfully, no.
Though these scratch pad prediction
tasks show above-chance accuracy,
the underlying correlations
are still pretty weak.
And though neural networks
are inspired by the brain,
they don't have the same kind
of structure and complexity
that we see in the brain.
Neural networks also
don't exist in the world.
A neural network has never opened a door
or seen a sunset, heard a baby cry.
Can a neural network that doesn't
actually exist in the world,
hasn't really experienced the world,
really understand language
about the world?
Still, these scratch pad prediction
experiments have held up --
multiple brain imaging experiments,
multiple neural networks.
We've also found that as the neural
networks get more accurate,
they also start to use
their scratch pad in a way
that becomes more brain-like.
And it's not just language.
We've seen similar results
in navigation and vision.
So AI is not doing exactly
what the brain is doing,
but it's not completely random either.
So from where I sit,
if we want to know if AI really
understands language like we do,
we need to get inside of the Chinese room.
We need to know what the AI is doing,
and we need to be able to compare that
to what people are doing
when they understand language.
AI is moving so fast.
Today, I'm asking you,
does AI understand language
that might seem like a silly
question in ten years.
Or ten months.
(Laughter)
But one thing will remain true.
We are meaning-making humans,
and we are going to continue
to look for meaning
and interpret the world around us.
And we will need to remember
that if we only look at the input
and output of AI,
it's very easy to be fooled.
We need to get inside
of the metaphorical room of AI
in order to see what's happening.
It's what's inside the counts.
Thank you.
(Applause)